Rauchwolken über Cape Canaveral.
Am Samstagnachmittag ist eine Crew Dragon-Kapsel
auf dem Teststand dort explodiert.
Sie wurde dabei komplett zerstört.
Das ist ein herber Rückschlag für das Raumfahrtprogramm
von Elon Musk.
Der Zeitplan noch dieses Jahr bemannte SpaceX-Kapseln
in den Weltraum zu schießen, dürfte damit
komplett über den Haufen geworfen sein.
Was ist passiert?
Wir zeigen es in einem Video und noch weitere
Details.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich
willkommen!
Das ist wirklich ein herber Rückschlag für
Space X. jetzt ist die Crew Dragon Kapsel
explodiert, die im März erfolgreich den ersten
testflug zur ISS absolviert hatte.
Getestet wurden die Booster der Crew Dragon,
mit dem die Kapsel im Notfall in der Lage
wäre sich in einem Notfall von der Falcon
Trägerrakete zu lösen und selbstständig
notzulanden.
Was genau explodiert ist, kann jetzt noch
nicht genau gesagt werden.
Die Explosion war so stark, dass sie auf Satellitenaufnahmen
zu sehen war.
Das ist auch nicht verwunderlich, denn diese
Triebwerke werden mit einem hochgiftigen extrem
explosiven Treibstoff betrieben.
Es handelt sich um eine hypergole Treibstoffmischung
aus Distickstofftetroxid und einer Hydrazin-Variante
ein.
Der Vorteile solcher Treibstoffe: Sie müssen
nicht wie herkömmliche Treibstoffe gezündet
werden, sondern reagieren sofort miteinander,
was sie für ein Notfallsystem zum idealen
Treibstoff macht.
Zudem müssen sie nicht gekühlt werden.
Der Nachteil: Sie sind eben extrem explosiv
und hochgiftig.
Schon einmal gab es eine solche Explosion.
Beim Start einer Titan 34D-Rakete am 18.
April 1986 hatte sich eine Verkleidung gelöst,
so dass die Hitze der Raketentreibwerke den
Treibstofftank erreichte und das gemisch zur
Explosion brachte.
Durch die niedergehenden brenenden Teile wurden
60 Menschen verletzt.
Mit der Rakete sollte ein Spionagesatellit
in den Erdorbit gebracht werden.
Da die Konstruktion als streng geheim klassifizeirt
war, wurde er bei dem Unfall durch einen Selbstzerstörungsmechanismus
zerstört.
Bei dem Unfall jetzt mit der Crew Dragon ist
nach ersten Meldungen niemand verletzt worden.
Noch halten sich NASA und SpaceX zurück.
NASA-Chef Jim Bridenstine "Deswegen testen
wir.
Wir werden daraus lernen und die notwendigen
Änderungen vornehmen, um unser kommerzielles
Mannschaftsbeförderungsprogramm sicher fortzusetzen."
SpaceX bleib auch sehr nüchtern: "SpaceX
führte heute eine Reihe von Triebwerkstests
an einem Crew-Dragon-Testraumschiff auf unserem
Teststand auf der Landezone 1 im Cape Canaveral
durch.
Die ersten Tests verliefen erfolgreich, aber
der letzte Test führte zu einer Anomalie
auf dem Teststand.
Sicherzustellen, dass unsere Systeme rigorosen
Sicherheitsstandards entsprechen und solche
Anomalien vor dem Flug zu finden, ist der
Hauptgrund, weshalb wir testen.
Unsere Teams arbeiten bei der Untersuchung
eng mit unseren Nasa-Partnern zusammen."
Anomalie heißt in diesem Fall eine schwere
Explosion mit der totalen Vernichtung der
Kapsel.
Auf Twitter war dieses Video zu sehen.
Schon einmal war eine Dragon Kapsel explodiert.
Auch damals gab es Probleme mit Treibstofftanks.
Der hochexplosive Treibstoff ist bei Raketenantrieben
immer wieder die Achillesferse.
Immer wieder kommt es egal ob Amerikaner,
Russen oder sonstwer zu Problemen.
Jetzt wird es spannend wie die Amerikaner
reagieren.
Kommt jetzt als erstes der Boeing CST-100
Starliner zum Einsatz?
Während die Crew Dragon ja schon Anfang März
ihren unbemannten Testflug absolviert hatte,
ist der für für die CST-100 Starliner für
Mitte August geplant.
Im November dann der erste Flug mit Besatzung.
Für die Crew Dargon war der eigentlich für
July geplant.
Jetzt wurde er für irgendwann in 2019 angekündigt.
Das Wettrennen zwischen Space X und Boeing
könnte hier für SpaceX verloren gehen.
Aber davon mal abgesheen: Diese Explosion
ruft uns wieder in Erinnerung, dass Raumfahrt
nichts alltägliches und mit hohen Risiken
behaftet ist.
Die fundamentale Bedeutung der Raumfahrt.
Darüber hat Neugierzone ein Video gemacht.
Draufklicken, anschauen und natülich Neugierzone
abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran.